i'm about to publish a book on algae
yeah and he's um
you know he's basically he's been there
for 50 years so he's like j edgar hoover
and the only way that you last that
agency for 50 years is by
carrying order for the pharmaceutical
industry and under his watch he's
supposed to prevent autoimmune and
allergic diseases
under his watch chronic disease has gone
from affecting 12 percent of the
american population to 54 percent we
take more pharmaceutical drugs than
anybody in the world we pay craziest
prices so we it's we he's made this
country pharmaceutical nation yeah my
brother's allergic to sesame seeds but
you know
exactly and the way that you get
allergies is from the aluminum adjuvant
in the vaccine which is
meant is put in that vaccine
to initiate an allergic response and it
and so if you have sesame seed oil as an
excipient in the vaccine or if you're if
you're eating sesame seeds when you have
that aluminum adjuvant in you
it can promote provoke an allergic
permanent allergy
and if you look you don't know anybody
who is my age who has food allergies
very very hard to find i think it's one
in something like 1300 and today okay if
you're born after he'll have a football
team yeah
everybody after 1989 so any anybody who
was born after 89 i think it's one in 12
now
autism went from 1 in 10 000 in my
generation to one in every 34 kids and
it's the same with all these chronic
diseases that are all listed as side
effects the modern vaccine was
completely developed by tony fauci
he hands it to a private group they then
they put two billion dollars of federal
money into allowing them to develop it
and then tony fauci's agency keeps half
the profits from the vaccine
oh it would be like you know i've sued
epa many times for being a captured
agency but you know what would what
would it be like if epa made half of its
profits
selling coal yeah it's the same thing
these agencies are not independent
agencies they're completely captured and
you have and you know the
all of the other institutions of
government that
that should stand between a greedy
corporation and a vulnerable child have
been compromised
congressman congress gets more money
lobbying money from the from the
pharmaceutical industry than any other
industry they give them double
what oil and gas cause i'm talking about
lobbyists
there's more pharma lobbyists on capitol
hill than there are congressmen senators
and supreme court justices combined
regulatory agencies have been captured
the press is utterly captured and that's
because
in 1997 we passed a law in this country
or fda you know changed regulation to
make it legal for the first time for
on television and radio and newspapers
to advertise pharmaceutical products on
the air direct to consumer farms when
was that what year was that i was 97 so
oh
there's only two countries in the world
that allow that everybody agrees a
terrible thing to do oh and it's half of
our commercials right now as well well
roger hills who founded fox told me that
that there are 22 commercials on his
average evening news show and 17 of
those are pharmaceutical oh yeah i'm
just trying to get through half a family
guy next thing you know i have hiv by
the end of the day so you know what i'm
saying it's just like the fear it's in a
lot of it's fear too and they give you
pictures of like oh here's a happy
family but you might have this looming
in the distance you know yeah you might
you know they list all these horrible
things from the side effects and the
people are walking around
happy and laughing and playing football
he said he just wants to do one of those
ads where people are actually acting out
the side effects
the idea that
we can trust an expert to tell us what's
good for us
every trial i've ever been involved with
there's an expert on both sides
and they're all both equally convincing
and that's why you need the debate yeah
that's why you know saying tony fauci
that's why people say
i want a second opinion yeah he's a
doctor he hasn't treated patients for 50
years
he's a doctor
but he doesn't know anything about
economics
he cannot tell you how many people are
dying of of um
of unemployment
there are studies from the 1980s there's
a famous study in 1982 in the 1980s
there was these huge downsizing and
layoffs that were occurring in our
country
and there was a whole cottage industry a
whole a school of economics that grew up
to see what happens to people when they
get unemployed
and there's one very famous study it's
it's cited hundreds of times
in the literature that said that for
every additional one point in
unemployment there's thirty seven
thousand americans die yeah
nine hundred nine thousand dive heart
attacks 900 from suicide and so on and
so on hypertension
diabetes all these lose their health
care all of these mad things there's a
cascade of bad things happen
our population was about half so you
have to double that
and say for every point in unemployment
we're going to lose maybe 60 000 dead
and otherwise would not have died
and are we start saving more lives are
we killing more people with the
quarantine than we are killing with
covet that's a great question nobody has
done that assessment and that's the
weird thing is people say listen to the
experts
but anthony fauci is not an expert on
deaths from unemployment
and you know and when
when britain did this study written
in five weeks in april and may
there were thirty thousand excess deaths
in elderly facilities which they call
nursing homes in britain
and only ten thousand of my coven
twenty thousand of them died from
isolation oh yeah i'm not shocked i mean
i noticed even just in my own like you
know going a 12-step and going to
recovery and not being able to have
those meetings and not being able to oh
i mean the addiction rates are i cannot
even imagine bro right
i cannot even imagine how like and you
and i know people
yeah
and died yeah you know during this where
people who couldn't go to our meetings
you know and it's a lot of people's
livelihood and that and that's a lot of
people and there's no talk like there's
just no talk about the human effect of
some of this it feels like sometimes
it's just about this weird medical
effect
or medical fear which kind of it's not
shocking then if big if if big pharma
and that money is is so slowly seeped
its arms all the way in everything that
at the very pinnacle of discussion the
only thing people are concerned about
the media is concerned about is
the medical effects of it and no longer
the human effects of it i mean anderson
cooper
ever
not once had an economist on [ __ ] bro i
don't know bro
[Laughter]
you know i mean that's just my thought
bro but
you know what i'm saying i'll put side
control on that dude in a heartbeat but
that's just me you know
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two options
watch one this one or this one